American apocalypse uh oh question mark
71% don't trust the US government to
prevent doomsday this is a study that
just came out yesterday obviously it's a
very inspiring story but let's go
through it a survey conducted by bonus
finder.com revealed that 71.2% of
Americans have lost faith in US
Government ability to save them from or
prevent a doomsday event with many
believing that such an event would occur
within the next year climate change
related catastrophic
were at the top concerned with 55.8% of
respondents fearing this type of
Doomsday scenario additionally a third
of respondents believe that another
virus could sweep the globe and 25%
feared the start of World War II a
smaller percentage considered scenarios
like an alien invasion or events in 2024
the lack of trust in US government was
bipartisan 82% of respondents in the
swing state of Arizona expressing
distrust some respondents 16% cited
social media and content they consume as
as influencing their doomsday
preparations While others pointed to
news family and movies okay uh Vinnie
what are your thoughts on this story
well first of all it's it's funny that
71% don't trust the government to
prevent doomsday aren't we at the
highest level of them don't trusting the
government to do anything period with
anything with politics and everything so
I think when it does come to a doomsday
event don't rely on the government don't
you have to rely on yourself and I'm not
talking about build a bunker or do
anything crazy like that but listen Pat
I I don't know if you have this do you
have do you have like a to go set up
ready to go just in case God forbid
something happens where shit's going
down you have to get everybody in the
car and go submarine parked outside the
house and and I'm being serious I have a
bag at my house the oh just in case
you got a go bag and obvious thank God
you know what I'm saying I'm armed I
have guns and stuff but MREs I went to
the Army Surplus Store you have that
people don't think about I'm dead
serious Adam I'm not one of those guys
that cuz you know Rob has a bunker in
Peter pry just go there to Peter pry
yeah but God God forbid and I'm hoping
it never happens let's just say Adam you
get that emergency alert that came on
everybody's phone yesterday and it's
something's really happening what are
you going to go like this no no you guys
go I'm waiting for the government FEMA's
going to send me a thing no no nobody's
going to give a it's going to be
every man for himself so I think you
have to be uh be prepared to take care
of you on your own I'll tell you what I
mean thank God you have that back the
only thing I have is like an overnight
sleepover back quick need you out here
boom I'm out I'm sleeping up boom with
your cats you have to bring your cats
extra bag of kibble there we go I think
um a lot of people normal people who
would look at Doomsday Preppers and you
see those commercials hey come over here
to you know Dooms Arkansas wherever
Oklahoma and get your piece of land and
go underground people like the hell
these guys talk weirdos now
they're like you know what yeah what was
that what was that place again what was
that thing again I think people are like
what's going on yeah the world has
changed so drastically but Pat brings up
up a great point we had this guy Peter
pry on he's I think he's the only guest
you had on back to backin a month really
and and then he died it was crazy what
did he die of not in the middle of the
podcast he died couple months after rest
his s there's a lot of people that
actually really love that guy super old
it's actually worth watching because he
talked about how to build a uh e EP what
was it called underground bunker yeah
underground but what it was called pmds
what was it called Rob Preppers no not
sure I got to go back and look it was
you know sort of like nuclear warfare
there was uh yeah here it is probably it
was right here oh yeah I do remember we
had back we had episode 155 and then
five episodes later we brought him back
to discuss and passed away was called
but you know but the whole conversation
I had with him was like you know Mr pry
Dr pry I totally understand what you're
saying but most people are struggling
you know 23s of Americans living
paycheck to paycheck we see debt On The
Rise we see people basically complaining
about inflation interest rates now
you're telling me I got to go buy some
piece of property underground bunker in
Oklahoma and I got like who's buying
this he's like look I I hear you but go
get it and the ironic thing God Rest his
soul he died turns out he didn't need he
didn't need it but I mean but at the
same time at least we have this Vault
and whatever property we get whatever
new property we get I totally recommend
that we hollow out the downstairs and
have one of
those little under by the way to be like
to be I'm not being funny what I'm
trying to tell you is have you seen the
Doomsday Bunkers like the highend luxury
go straight down P they rob can you show
this link I'm sending to you they kind
of sweet no no some of these things and
no like yeah it's actually a big thing
right that that one right there one
right there watch this 11 uh luxury
doomsday this is real this is
underground what the hell yes zoom in a
little bit so we can see the pictures
like trump top Plaza underground what
for only 17 grand a night you can keep
going so this is an underground
apartment what yes keep going this is
another one keep going this is a condo
under look at that goes my God bro if
you got the money if you got the money
it looks like that building in Chicago
you see the the circular building down
building going down oh my God imag can
you imagine that trident Lake keep going
yeah get the prices on these though
that's what I want to know the pric onas
Las Vegas underground shelter look at
this kids playground running around
doing their thing there's a game by the
way if if you can't afford one of these
you better befriend somebody that's one
of those crazy doomsday guys this that
house right there looks like that one
house where once a year you can kill
people Purge or whatever it's called
Purge that's a purge house keep going
lower okay look at these houses straight
up by the way Bunk b right next to each
other like military keep going keep
going keep going Pat what's the
percentage of Elites that you think I'm
talking about the real Rich that have
the there people that are actually talk
our
language
anyway to our to our viewers out there
don't that wasn't uh some weird audio
stuff that's just their seran language
goes back thousands of years guys don't
worry
about that just said that they're going
to go buy a doomsday preper outfit right
there Vinnie but you know why you can't
do it in Florida here we can't buy one
in Florida the G aquifer is in the way
because we're basically like a few feet
above water if we go any lower here
we'll be swimming so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here